MEMOS.
NEW FOX POLLS OUT THIS HOUR ON
HOW THE PRESIDENT IS DOING.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I AM BRET BAIER.
AN ADMINISTRATION UNDER FIRE
TONIGHT AND AT THIS HOUR, THERE
IS NO SIGN THAT ANYONE IS
BACKING DOWN.
THE PRESIDENT'S PICK FOR VA
SECRETARY DR. RONNY JACKSON
PLANS TO STAND FIRM AGAINST
ALLEGATIONS OF IMPROPER CONDUCT
AND TO PRESS FORWARD WITH HIS
NOMINATION.
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
GETS INTO A TESTY EXCHANGE ON
CAPITOL HILL OVER PRESIDENTIAL
PARDONS AND THE OMB DIRECTOR AND
CURRENT HEAD OF THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU MICK
MULVANEY PUSHES BACK HARD ON
NEWSPAPER REPORTS ABOUT COMMENTS
HE MADE IN A SPEECH THIS WEEK
ABOUT LOBBYIST ACCESS TO HIS
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICE.
IT'S WEDNESDAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS JOINS US WITH THE
LATEST.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING.
A BUSY ONE.
TODAY DEMOCRATS WITHOUT ANY
EVIDENCE TO BACK IT UP RELEASED
A LAUNDRY LIST OF ALLEGATIONS
AND ACCUSATIONS AGAINST
DR. RONNY JACKSON, THE MAN
PRESIDENT WANTS TO LEAVE THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS ADMINISTRATION.
AMONG THE ALLEGATIONS ARE
ACCUSATIONS HE MISHANDLED OPIOID
DRUGS AND THAT AT A
SECRET SERVICE PARTY HE GOT
DRUNK AND WRECKED A GOVERNMENT
VEHICLE.
AFTER MEETING WITH THE PRESS
SECRETARY AND CHIEF OF STAFF
LATE TODAY, DR. RONNY JACKSON
DISMISSED NEW DEMOCRATIC
ALLEGATIONS THAT HE WRECKED A
GOVERNMENT VEHICLE AFTER GETTING
DRUNK AT A SECRET SERVICE PARTY,
INSISTING IT NEVER HAPPENED AND
THAT HE IS GOING TO GO AHEAD
WITH THE CONFIRMATION PROCESS.
THE PRESS SECRETARY TODAY SAYING
NONE OF THE ALLEGATIONS NOW
RAISED ABOUT JACKSON WERE
UNCOVERED IN SUCCESSIVE
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
>> DR. JACKSON HAS HAD AT LEAST
FOUR INDEPENDENT BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATIONS CONDUCTED DURING
HIS TIME AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
DURING EACH OF THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS, DR. JACKSON
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS PRAISE FROM
DOZENS OF WITNESSES AND THE
INVESTIGATIONS REVEALED NO AREAS
OF CONCERN.
FIGURE SARAH SANDERS NOTING NONE
OF THE ALLEGATIONS WERE RAISED
BEFORE JACKSON'S NOMINATION.
THE BACKGROUND CHECK SHOULD HAVE
PICKED UP A MEDICAL
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT IN
2012 THAT FOUND DR. JACKSON
EXHIBITED POOR LEADERSHIP IN A
DISPUTE WITH A COLLEAGUE AND AS
A RESULT OF THE DISPUTE, OVERALL
UNIT MORALE IS A 2 ON A SCALE OF
1 TO 10.
ONE OF HIS BIGGEST DETRACTORS IS
MONTANA SENATOR JON TESTER,
RANKING MEMBER OF THE VA
COMMITTEE WHO INSISTS JACKSON
HAS PROBLEMS BEYOND LEADERSHIP.
>> THIS DOCTOR HAS A PROBLEM
BECAUSE HE HANDS OUT
PRESCRIPTIONS LIKE CANDY.
IN FACT, IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
THEY CALLED THE CANDY MAN.
THE WORD IS THAT IT ON OVERSEAS
TRIPS IN PARTICULAR THE ADMIRAL
WILL GO DOWN THE AISLE AND SAY
WHO WANTS TO GO TO SLEEP AND
HANDOUT THE PRESCRIPTIONS.
>> ON OVERNIGHT OVERSEAS TRIPS,
WHITE HOUSE DOCTORS DO AFTER
STAFF, EVEN JOURNALISTS, SLEEP
AIDS.
>> AROMATIC GOVERNMENT -- I
RECOMMEND EVERYONE TAKES A SLEEP
AID AT CERTAIN
TIMES.
>> THE PILLS GIVEN OUT ARE
RECORDED WITH NAMES AND DOSAGES.
TESTER'S COMMENT DREW SHARP
RESPONSE.
>> IT WAS ABSOLUTELY UNFAIR FOR
HIM TO DROP THE CANDYMAN LINE.
THERE HAVE BEEN MULTIPLE, EVERY
YEAR THEY COME IN AND DO A
REVIEW OF THE WHITE HOUSE
PHYSICIAN'S OFFICE ON THINGS
LIKE PRESCRIPTIONS.
EVERY YEAR THEY HAVE SAID HE IS
IN COMPLIANCE WITH WHAT HE'S
BEEN PRESCRIBING.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE CONTINUES TO
PUSH SENATOR JOHNNY ISAKSON TO
RESCHEDULE THE CONFIRMATION
HEARING.
ALSO ON CAPITOL HILL TODAY,
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
UNDER FIRE OVER REPORTS HIS
RECUSAL FROM THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION DOES NOT EXTEND TO
THE INVESTIGATION OF MICHAEL
COHEN.
>> ARE YOU RECUSED FROM THE
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION OF THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY, MICHAEL
COHEN?
>> IT'S THE POLICY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT THOSE
WHO HAVE RECUSED THEMSELVES NOT
STATE THE DETAILS OF IT.
>> SESSIONS GOT INTO A HEATED
EXCHANGE WITH DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR CHRIS VAN HOLLEN OVER
PRESIDENTIAL PARDONS AND WHETHER
THEY WENT THROUGH THE
APPROPRIATE PROCESS.
>> DID THE PARDON OF
SHERIFF JOSEPH ARPAIO GO THROUGH
THE ATTORNEY'S OFFICE?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT DID.
>> DID THE PARDON OF SCOOTER
LIBBY GO THROUGH?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT DID.
>> I AM QUOTING FROM A STATEMENT
YOU MADE SAYING IT IT WAS AN
ABUSE OF PROCESS AND A
PARTICULAR CASE MADE BY
PRESIDENT CLINTON.
>> THE PARDONS PRESIDENT CLINTON
MADE WERE SHOCKING, STUNNING,
AND ON A COMFORTABLE.
>> ALSO FACING HEAT, THE
PRESIDENTS BUDGET DIRECTOR MICK
MULVANEY OVER COMMENTS MADE
YESTERDAY IN A SPEECH TO BANKERS
AND PAYDAY LENDERS.
SPEAKING IS THAT OF THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU,
MULVANEY TOLD THE GROUP IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO MAKE PERSONAL
CONTACT WITH THEIR MEMBER OF
CONGRESS TO GET THINGS DONE.
MULVANEY SAYING WE HAD A
HIERARCHY IN MY OFFICE AND
CONGRESS.
IF YOU ARE A LOBBYIST WHO NEVER
GAVE US MONEY, I DIDN'T TALK TO
YOU.
IF YOU ARE A LOBBYIST WHO GAVE
US MONEY, I MIGHT TALK TO YOU.
IF YOU CAME FROM BACK HOME AND
SAT IN MY LOBBY, I TALKED TO YOU
WITHOUT EXCEPTION REGARDLESS OF
THE FINANCIAL CONTRIBUTIONS.
DEMOCRATS POUNCED ON THE
REMARKS, SLAMMING MULVANEY FOR
PROMOTING PAY TO PLAY.
IN A STATEMENT, OHIO
SENATOR RIPPING THE KIND OF PAY
TO PLAY THAT UNDERSTANDABLY
MAKES AMERICANS FURIOUS WITH
WASHINGTON, D.C.
MR. MULVANEY SHOULD RESIGN.
MULVANEY SPOKESMAN INSISTS THE
COMMENTS WERE TAKEN OUT OF
CONTEXT AND HE WAS FROM MERELY
PRAISING THE GROUP FOR COMING TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND MAKING THE
EFFORT TO KNOCK ON DOORS.
ANY DEVELOPMENT THIS AFTERNOON
IN THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION,
SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THAT
RUDY GIULIANI HAS TAKEN OVER
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER FOR A
POSSIBLE INTERVIEW WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SAID HE, HAS